[Music]
very large mammals like hippos elephants
and rhinos were once much more
widespread throughout the world perhaps
we're standing in a moment looking at
the remnants of the last true mega
herbivores on their way to extinction
forcing them over the edge Ivor
is not our right day after day for the
past eight years since the first
relocation started he has followed the
signals and he tracks his friends
because he is determined to play a role
in recreating wilderness
[Music]
for centuries African cultures have had
more laws and rules governing just how
to behave towards the earth than they
did about people securing the lives of
these often weird animals and living
with wildlife not against
[Music]
they viewed the earth the Rhinos that
wallet in it the wind the birds the
trees and us all as one living thing
they believe that whether each of us is
a spirit or an animal different for each
for encore it is the Rhino
for Botswana it is also the time of the
great long-horned Reiner building a
healthy population in Botswana game as
they slowly define territories and
gather occasionally at water holes
[Music]
as they test their skills as potential
territorial males they are displaying a
comfort with being safe and a part of
that old relationship that the African
people so relished and it is clear why
if this rebuilding of a complex
wilderness is going to work at all it'll
work here it is a place where private
Safari companies individuals lagoon poor
government departments of Wildlife and
their anti poaching teams Botswana
military and a president with a passion
for seeing his country whole again all
work together and of course in their own
way the Rhinos themselves are fixing us
there is an old curse in Africa one that
settles like a deep fog on the wives and
children of those who kill a rhino
protecting them now seems to be
something we've been given to do by
those ancient voices
run run I run but this time you can run
free and wild